pour le moment coulisses info rigola de
retour sur la première grande soirée
télé de la présidentielle un rendez vous
manqué 4,2 millions pour la france face
à la guérison coupé en deux et 3,1 la
deuxième partie il faut savoir que le
grand débat sur tf1 20 mars 2017 ça va
vous faire rêver avait fait 9
millions de téléspectateurs 9 8 millions
sans découpage
47,9 eric vous rendez compte c'est fou -
et cesser ces problématiques voilà
florian cindy qui va venir nous voir
dans un instant et c'est vrai qu'on va
vous raconter cette soirée on va vous
dire on va vous dire ce qu'on en a pensé
dès le début c'est un petit peu mal
parti 20h24 tf1 décide d'enchaîner
direct son jt avec l'émission politique
mais bon on avait plus l'impression
qu'on était sur ses huit c'était pas
vrai non plus elle avait l'impression
qu'on verrait dans une de mes émissions
regardées claire coudray et gilles
bouleau bonsoir à tous les deux
être honnête on va être en lettres merci
julien bienvenue à tous voilà donc là on
était sur ses buts on s'est dit c'est
sympa moi j'aime bien des jamaïque et
florian cindy qui nous a rejoint bien
sûr expert en communication politique un
ami en plus florian vous allez me dire
ce que vous avez pensé bien sûr de
donner la soirée d'hier vous êtes le
fondateur de la french comme alors 2e
20h25 l'émission commence et on voudra
revenir sur le décor le décor ils ont
construit un plateau comme si il y
allait avoir un
à un au togo j'ai cru qu'elle avoir
boubakary ce cas là un fact de mm à
regarder
[Applaudissements]
champion du monde champion olympique
amateurs président sortant vous briguer
un second mandat en 2010 est petit
rappel vous aviez recueilli au premier
tour 24 % des voix il est revenu sur le
ring c'était cet été
mon soir emmanuel bacon bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mesdames bonsoir messieurs
vous avez pensé de la soirée que l'on
pouvait pas faire plus raté on pourra
plus passer à côté de la cible tf1 nous
a promis dans différentes interviews
préalable à la diffusion de ce format
qu'on on assisterait à quelque chose
qu'on n'avait jamais vu dans son
dynamisme c'est simple je pense qu'on
n'a jamais rien vu d'aussi peu dynamique
que cela précise
alors je me fais l'avocat du diable tf1
s'est pas tellement de leur faute aussi
puisque les candidats voulait pas
débattre
c'est un peu facile de se retrancher
derrière la volonté de tel ou tel
candidat d'éviter la confrontation au
fond ils avaient tous intérêt à éviter
la confrontation mais ce n'est pas le
rôle de la chaîne que de se soumettre
aux desiderata des conseillers en
communication on a avec ce format jamais
autant abîmer l'image des politiques
vous en avez une partie qui s'est
complètement ridiculiser totalement mal
à l'aise au milieu de ce ring
manifestement pas briché bas on en a vu
certains et certaines s'agiter de
manière ridicule ne pas savoir poser
leur voix enfin bref ils sont passés à
côté de l'exercice on en a vu qui était
pas mal en revanche mélenchon marine le
pen ils ont plutôt su tirer globalement
leur candidature vers le haut j'ai
trouvé j'ai trouvé marine le pen
mélenchon le président
a été très bon j'ai adoré
incessamment roussel comme moi excellent
je comprends pas pourquoi c'est pas le
candidat de gauche willis et le meilleur
c'est vrai et c'est le meilleur il dit
les choses n est pas moi moi je ris hier
j'ai vu des missions j'ai été vraiment
séduit par ce gars vraiment je vous dis
pour moi c'est les caps qui ont réussi
leurs émissions florent vous êtes vous
êtes d'accord avec nous oui mais je
crois que on ne peut plus proposer aux
français une succession de monologues de
cette façon là sans débat sans
confrontation sans challenge et les
candidats puisque aujourd'hui à l'heure
où les français nous déclarent
massivement qu'ils ne sont pas
intéressés par cette candidature que
l'on sait qui rit il ya un risque
d'abstention très fort plus on va
laisser les candidats dans un tunnel de
prise de parole sans confrontation sans
contradictions et plus les français
auront du mal à s'intéresser à ses
formes
c'est un gros sujet d'ailleurs il ya un
autre sujet qui me paraît extrêmement
sensible tf1 en nous promettant un
dynamisme ils nous ont aussi promis un
respect très rigoureux des règles de
l'art comme l'excès ça on s'est retrouvé
avec une violation totale de à peu près
tout ce que fait toutes les volontés de
rideau des règles de l'art comme on a eu
sur twitter le président de la
république ultra représenté pendant que
tous les candidats ont été largement
sous traité on a eu le présent la
république il ya eu un temps de parole
largement supérieur aux autres aussi et
donc à la fois sur le plateau et sur les
réseaux sociaux il y à un non respect
évident de des règles posées par la
commission quand même un espace clair
ces cas ils nous regardent tous les
soirs
en disant que tf1 était dans les règles
voilà mon avis elle veut être embauchés
la base à partir du cnrs pour aller chez
tf1 claire s'écaille c'est donc ce que
claire c'est qu'alors je dis c'est là
c'est la mode du cnrs voilà qui nous
regardent tous les soirs d'ailleurs
aussi faire beau bisous et et ses seins
parce qu'elle me laisse toujours des
petits mots hyper gentil en message
privé
et desquelles mme ait un toit
c'est le sas et c'est toujours mon
mécène privé national hamid si j'aime
beaucoup les médias n'assument pas
l'amitié et voilà ça va on va finir
ensemble ça devait finir au cnrs le
plateau était celle où est une
organisation tout aussi bizarre la
preuve tous les candidats étaient
complètement perdus tout au long des
missions
fallait revoir ouais ils ont fait pire
merci beaucoup anne hidalgo nous
accueillons maintenant valérie pécresse
je
vous êtes allez merci beaucoup faire dao
celle d'avoir merci tenu le temps qui
vous était imparti et ce n'est qu'à leur
voix merci beaucoup jean luc mélenchon
l'autre côté de la rue en prit pars là
bas c'est par où c'est par la ceiba
l'acfc monsieur mélenchon comme nous sur
le tour doit toujours avoir défini
laïque non je vous accompagne par le
petit jeu en veillant matin monsieur
zemmour il va me mordre voilà il joue et
qu'il
n'y avait pas de débat les candidats ont
voulu envoyer quelques punchs times et
certains se sont crus en voile man
c'était c'est tout pour moi
comme aujourd'hui
tout le monde le vit vous devez lviv la
station d'essence c'est le seul endroit
où on tient le pistolet et on s'est
braqué
samedi un produit de luxe bientôt on va
aller au jerrycans chercher son
jerricane à essence logoté au coco
chanel c'est un débat à voir avec la
grande distribution qui parfois à
tendance un peu alors serrer le kiki il
faut être ces mesures arrivent beaucoup
trop tard pourquoi le 1er avril il ya un
poisson quelque chose
c'est pas évident pour les candidats
parce que arrivé comme ça c'est un c'est
un ring c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
quoi la maison de moyens d'action et
mais je suis désolé ne rien faire cette
émission déjà pardon et le titre la
france face à la guerre ça aurait
absolument pas ce qu'on adore que c'est
rien à voir a créé les habitants et pour
émission voilà la noble en scène était
terrible loring effectivement ça se
prête aux débats y avait aucun débat les
candidats étaient profondément mal à
l'aise physiquement c'est très dur de se
tenir droite son pupitre comme ça devant
300 personnes et puis par an mais cette
succession au début de ce pitch d'une
minute on aurait dit un speed dating
pour moi ça se prêtait pas du tout à ce
genre d'émission c'est le nombre
d'allers-retours l'envoyer qui se
perdent et sous le bateau je suis un
petit ça va pas du tout aux antilles et
les titres à la française que tu veux la
france face à la présidentielle la
france face à son avenir la france face
à la guerre des étoiles c'est quoi le
rapport il arrive tout de suite eu alors
ce qui se passe en ukraine mais pourquoi
tu me parles de l'ukraine rade on
cherche un président et l'irt en train
de me parler de l'ukraine arrête est
gentil mais ne parle moi de ton
programme en fait on s'est parlé dans
mon camp sont là mais c'est toi l'envers
21h44 le président candidat emmanuel
wallon antre en plateau pour son
entretien avec gilles bouleau et anne
claire coudray
il était en galère avec emmanuel macron
parce qu'ils n'osaient pas voilà y aller
en fait il est après le têt sirpa
ils ont passé leur temps à le couper j'y
crois moi qui voulais dire conscient
macro prenez place restait debout ou
asseyez-vous
la chasse que nous sommes en retard mais
c'est pas la même chose que quand on est
derrière son bureau donc il faut il faut
pas d'apposer la dernière escale rapport
à part ça pardon est aux fourneaux
compte tenu
d'un ensemble à la dernière qu'elle
suppose aussi de savoir mieux
accompagner pour des enseignants ces
manuels devant une classe merci beaucoup
emmanuel macron d'avoir répondu en tant
que candidat alors ça je me tourne vers
son ça le truc ya c'est comme on dit
souvent dit les gens disent oui tf1 et
avantages emmanuel macron ils ont voulu
en faire des caisses en fait pour faire
genre on est contre eux on a rappelé
l'urd a coupé le président le dit qu'on
est en retard vous avez vu on est con on
est allé quand même sur le président
series ont simulé au fond un exercice
difficile pour le président de la
république alors qu'ils ont été
totalement inexistant avec les autres
ils n'ont d'ailleurs pas arrêté de
répéter qu'ils étaient bienveillants
pour qu'on retienne cela 2 alors que
c'est pas ce qu'on attend de leur
présence aux côtés des candidats on
attend qu'il mette en avant des
contradictions qui les pousse dans leurs
retranchements c'est d'ailleurs dans ces
moments-là que les candidats sont les
meilleurs cette émission pour moi elle
fait l'effet d'un amant un puissant
c'est une déception on assure promis on
s'est retrouvés à lyon deux choses sur
tf1 et son la grosse émission la
présidente est maintenant déception
surtout des consommateurs ouais mais
c'est sorti plus fort en tant qu on a
zappé - cole flattait ça fait fuir les
noms l'émission a duré jusqu'à 23h15
c'est moins long que mes émissions un
joli ils ont été plus efficaces sur tf1
que moi demain je suis avec marine le
pen à mon avis ça va durer six à quatre
heures du matin non non ça va être à 23
heures tout le monde rentre à la maison
ça a été long pour les téléspectateurs
qui est en train de manger des chips sur
le canap fonds d'imaginer public de 300
personnes présentes pendant trois heures
ils attendaient juste rentrer dormir
troisième chose je veux que l'on prenne
en compte les différences dans les
carrières unique
une
première
pour la paix bien sûr je pense que nous
avons
la différence
et c'est la vraie indépendance c'est la
france
23h50 fin d'émission chaque candidat
avait le droit à une petite conclusion
ce qui s'inspirait de françois hollande
et de son voix président de la
république alors ce qu'on appelle des
bernadette sanaa foraine a fait
exactement les anaphore regardez par
exemple eric zemmour qui visiblement
kiffe le 26 à mon avis c'est son chiffre
fétiche et doit jouer à la roulette 1
en vérité il n'est plus temps de
réformer la france mais de la sauver oui
il nous reste 26 jours 26 jours 26 jours
26 jours 26 jours 26 jours 26 jours 26
jours 26 jours 26 jours 26 jours 26
jours il ne restera ce fan ci joint
merci beaucoup eric mercier ce parterre
26 qu'est ce qu'on a vu hier c'est que
c'est vrai que là c'est un exercice
difficile et on voit que ceux qui ont le
plus de bouteille l'ont réussi yes man
conte mêlant chine selon le pen mais on
s'est raconté surprise mais c'est vrai
que voilà c'est ce temps le plus de
bouteilles qui ont réussi le simple
orient mais c'est peut-être aussi seuls
qui ont le plus travaillé on voit bien
qu'un certain nombre de candidats sont
allés sur le plateau en terrain conquis
et non pas travailler n'ont pas adapté
leur message n'ont pas eu envie de
parler aux français concrètement et
efficacement
on n'a pas avec cette émission donner
envie aux français de s'intéresser à la
politique d'aller voter pour les uns en
lisant ça rien changer il ya un
emballement j'en ai imposé aux français
si je pense que ça les a fait fuir une
partie des français qui était déjà très
désintéressé par cette campagne et que
donc c'est un danger démocratique et que
ça devrait appeler au sursaut toutes les
chaînes de télévision qui ne doivent
plus organiser ce genre de choses c'est
au fond l'exemple parfait ne pas suivre
je pense que ce format il a été imaginé
par des gens qui n'ont jamais fait de
télé qui n'ont pas voulu intéresser les
français à la chose politique et ça
c'est un problème demain demain je vous
rappelle que rafa s'abat en direct un et
rapide sur ces vite c'est demain c'est
bien mercredi avec marine le pen qui
sera en début d'émission face à marlène
schiappa et juste après passage on
messire merci en tout cas florian sydney
qui d'avoir été avec nous c'est toujours
avec un bonheur
on